hey what's up guys my name is Jenna
welcome to Episode one of a brand-new
series so this is more of a miniseries I
like to call it because it is going to
be kind of short so game programming 3d
game programming those are all series
that are just really looked long this
one's only going to be a few episodes
it's probably going to be around 10 or
so I'll try and explain everything
though so we'll see how it how it ends
up
but basically what is it so this series
is I haven't actually thought of a name
yet so I don't know what the title of
this video is going to be but basically
what we're going to be making is
something called Cherno chat I've just
called it that basically is going to be
a chat client and server in which you
can send messages to each other so in
other word there's going to be a central
server there's going to be multiple
clients that you can give to anyone you
want in the world and whenever they log
in to the client and they say something
everyone else who has that client open
will actually receive those messages so
it's basically an instant messaging
system now why am I doing this okay this
is this is application programming this
isn't game programming in any form and
that's a lot done um on my channel so
why am i doing this well actually I did
morning coffee because I sonto actually
game-related but anyway why am i doing
is big it the actual reason is because
we're about to dive into multiplayer and
game programming and it's such a such an
abstract concept that I thought that
it'd be good to just break it down to
its core which you know have basically
like if as soon as you learn programming
like let's make a calculator this that's
what most people like as soon as you
learn multiplayer you'll like let's make
a chalk line because that's like one of
those things it's like the hello world
of actual multiplayer um communication
so that's what we're going to do okay um
so this episode is going to be pretty
short it's just going to be like an
introduction to this series it's not
actually going to be writing an
incapable creative window though but
apart from that it is going to be pretty
simple and I will be putting all this
source code onto github so you guys can
actually just download it and look at it
um it will be open source it will have a
license though so if you want to use it
in your own code or distribute it you'll
actually have to enclose the license as
well but that'd be more information
about that in the actual license file
but the code is open source so yeah and
it is on github and the link to that
will be in the description as well as
the link to something more about install
here so we're actually going to it
ourselves
in Eclipse I am oh yeah probably
mentioned that I'm on Mac I'm not on
Windows right now now I actually tweeted
in facebook that I was gonna possibly
try Mac and if I should and a lot a lot
of people said you know into Windows a
lot of people said to Mac I thought I'd
just do Mac now the reason I'm doing Mac
is because I'm still in Germany on my
little holiday and I don't have a really
powerful computer with me and the thing
is I've got this MacBook Pro which I've
had since 2010 it's actually a 2010
15-inch model the top of the range 2010
15 inch model but it's still pretty slow
in Windows um because well yeah it's
Windows so what I've done is I've
decided to actually use map just because
it's a little faster especially on the
video editing side of things so that's
why I'm using Mac here and I thought I
just mix it up okay one more thing I
wanted to mention was that yeah my
preferred development environment is
Windows though and you should be able to
follow along with this tutorial whether
you're using Windows Linux or Mac so
yeah okay so to get started we're going
to install a plugin into a club so this
is Eclipse I am using a Juno I believe
version 4.2.2 you can see right here you
don't need to use this exact version
although you might need to I don't know
if you can use capital of this and the
reason you can't use Kepler possibly
again just I'm just spontaneously saying
that the reason you probably can't use
Kepler maybe is because the plug-in
might not be upgraded for that is some
serious rain outside anyway I might
close the window sorry for that
that's right about that I just wanted to
not get too much rain and holy crap it's
amazing sorry it's been like 35 degrees
here like every day and now it's raining
anyway sorry back to this um so yeah the
plug-in might not support care player
because Kepler think is still in bed I'm
not sure okay so what you want to do in
eclipse is go to help which is up the
top here and hit install new software
that's how you install plugins into
Eclipse okay you can't actually manually
download them to do that now what we're
going to do is we're actually work with
window builder okay that's what we're
going to be installing now the link to
this is right over here I will put I
will post it into the into the
description of this video so you'll be
able to download as well but basically
what you'll have to do is grab that link
which I just did hit the Add button name
it what
you want and then just paste the link in
here and hit okay again then you'll get
it into here with the work under the
work with Dropbox so select a window
builder and then what you'll see here is
a bunch of stuff come up you want to
select all of it okay just hit the
select all button that's it and hit next
it's going to calculate requirements and
dependencies blah blah hit next
accept the terms after rating of course
and hit finish and it's basically just
going to install software I'm going to
just fast forward through this because
might take a while alright so once it
finishes downloading and installing
you'll have to restart and clips as you
can see here so just hit the yes button
and Eclipse will restart hopefully yeah
dinner there it is I actually wanted to
put a quick disclaimer as well in front
of this entire series I'm not a
professional programmer by any means I'm
18 years old and I'm actually still in
university the only educational
certification I have at all in
programming is a high distinction in
introduction to programming and
algorithmic problem solving okay that's
it that's it that's just that's it so
all this code that I write here it's
completely just it's my way of doing
things it might not be the most
efficient way of doing things but that's
just what you get so just that's my
disclaimer out of the way okay sweet so
now that we've hopefully got when to
build a correctly installed what you'll
have to do now is making project now
I've already got one here and the reason
I've already got one here is because I
am going to be again using github for
this and that's why you know if you do
that if you use github you have to set
it up differently now what you can do is
you can actually grab my projects
straight from github if you don't want
to type the code by yourself I highly
recommend that you make a new project a
local project or whatever github project
and actually copy down the code line by
line like you do with game programming
because um it's just going to teach you
about I don't know four hundred and
fifty times more specifically that
amount by the way so honestly just write
the code down now if you really don't
want to or whatever we use one or if you
just want to follow along with me this
way you you can just sync it up with
github okay and if you guys don't know
how to do that and you can't find any
good tutorials out there because it is
actually pretty complicated just
drop a comment and I might make it a
tutorial on how to basically um clone
repository from github into Eclipse and
some of that okay anyway so really all
you have to do is hit file new Java
project call it Cherno Chad call it
whatever you want and I'll be using one
point six because Mac doesn't actually
have one point seven yes it does it's
embarrassing but uh maybe does I'm not
sure but anyway I'll be using one point
six then aren't that different a special
veges they've got a few advanced
features like multiple try catching
thing is which are very useful but
anyway we won't near that probably for
this um we'll be using one by six and
then just hit finish and that's it okay
but we've already got one called
chan-ocha here and that's what I'll be
using but yeah you'll have to make your
own okay so now that we've got
everything installed we can actually
make a window quickly so on source here
I'm just going to right click hit new
and I'm not going to create a new class
I'm actually going to go to other okay
and in other on the window builder what
you should see is a bunch of different
things now on the swing designer there
should be J frame that's what we want to
create okay not an application window
don't actually even know what that is we
want to describe a new jframe and then
hit next we want to give it a name now
this is exactly like the class the new
class thing okay we'll have to give it a
package socom dot the Cherno dot tarnish
out and I'll just call it login okay
because the first thing we're gonna do
is make a new login just just a login
window so that we can handle that and
then hit finish and wait for it to
create and hopefully what you'll see is
this okay now this is very interesting
because well we get a bunch of code here
automatically generated for us but if we
hit design down the bottom this is where
the fun part starts up we actually once
it passes all the code here it will
actually create this for us and this is
awesome because what this is is
basically visual studios drag-and-drop
thing bitten in Eclipse and for Java so
this is it just enormous ly helpful for
application development now you don't
actually have to do this you don't have
to download window builder even though
we just did I recommend it because it'll
just save you a lot of time but
to see all of this code you can type by
yourself so you don't actually need to
do this but that being said it will just
speed up your development by a lot okay
and then from this you can drag on any
components you want and it'll generate
code for it
okay that's all we're going to do today
because this video is getting long
enough but that's basically how it's
going to work okay so just to clean this
up a bit I'm going to just add a default
serial version idea we don't need
generate one and I just just adjust this
just a like my opinion I really don't
like having the main method as like like
here I liked it I like having it as the
last method so I'm going to cut it and
paste it at the end that's just again
just best preference not necessary and
let's get rid of these Java comments
because well we need them for this and
yeah and that's it okay umm yeah the
other thing is for some reason
windowbuilder always likes to put the
window at 100 100 so if I launch it for
example quickly here waiting the debug
button you'll see it's actually it's not
in the center I kind of like it to be
there so what I want to do is this set
bounce thing where we're not going to
touch it for now until we actually
finish because what happens is if we
actually modify it now as in just get
rid of it and use other methods to set
size and set location then what's going
to happen is when we resize the window
in window builder is going to actually
reset it but some of these things will
change manually but although other than
that we have a little window here and
that's what we're going to start with in
episode 2 so I hope you enjoyed this
episode of cheer node chat whatever I
haven't named the series yet but I'll
see you guys next time good bye
you
[Music]